I mean, you're a teacher, Taylor.
Be honest. What do you make?
And I wish he hadn't done that.
Ask me to be honest because you see, I have a policy...
...about honesty and ass kicking which is...
...if you ask for it, then I have to let you have it.
You wanna know what I make?
I make kids work harder than they ever thought they could!
I can make a C+ feel like a Congressional Medal of Honor...
...and I can make an A- feel like a slap in the face.
How dare you waste my time with anything less than your very best!
You wanna know what I make?
I make kids sit through 40 minutes of study hall in absolute silence.
No, you cannot work in groups.
No, you can't ask a question, so put your hand down.
Why won't I let you go to the bathroom?
Because you're bored, and you don't really have to go, do you?